One day, when Ali Baba was in the forest,...
...he saw some robbers coming towards him.
Ali Baba was afraid of them so he climbed a tree.
The robbers rode up to the cave.
When they got to it, one of them shouted, "Open sesame!".
Immediately, a door opened in the cave.
The robbers were inside for a long time.
Then the door opened, and they came out.
One of them shouted, "Close sesame!".
And immediately, the door in the cave closed.
The robbers went away.
Ali Baba climbed down from the tree.
He stood in front of the cave.
"What is inside the cave?" he thought.
"Open sesame!" he shouted to the cave.
Immediately, a door opened into the cave.
Ali Baba went inside.
He was very surprised.
The cave was full of bags of gold coins.